я я хотіла чудово ти шо наша позиція
міністерства усвяти
в принципі падаючи з міністерством
фінансів у тому що соціальні стипендії
вимагати та ти сама міністерству
соціальної політики там ще у нас дуже
багато різних соціальних кішки в кішках
усвяти
і потім виходить що з ввп яків нас ви з
кокаїном світу ви але порушені соціальним
та доплати ви там у соціальної стипендії
ми з радістю вид додому міністерству
соціальної політики та там його вас попит
йому щоб не стр соціальна політика
youtube постанова допитувала за годину ти
не соціальних стипендій
будь ласка вигуки ви будете раз
курятником з їхньої кішки будь ласка
подавитися ми готові там 5 на сус три
члена свого за старих ти маєш рацію у всіх
цих категорій тому що нас правді
категорії маяч проблеми та новачки
виплати ікебани ось риби сьогодні вид
тримаючи вище їх не синій задоволений mather не
цьому центрі павутини ти про всіх цих
виплат
чим може ти мета опціях виплат ікебани
сьогодні вранці і
ну покрита їм потрібні звістка виживання від
риси такі березня до дати c соціальна
стипендія
ми поклоняємось у чому вона міністр
соціальної політики та крію три матчі
інформації у всіх соціальних виплат
краї не для різних категорій ці
вимагатиме цикл із виплат
та політика
на
зайняти оборону на всіх яка
роздрукуй виплату
так будь ласка
палати світ пагорбів проректор карибському
міністерству почти так тут камер сюди
Усе
я пан за міністерства праці
крима програма міністерства
скиглики ви axe
цей вузлів цієї ас я скажу про
провисання думаю що за расу.
роман Володимирович і Сергій Михайлович
він же че я правильно з
розумію і такса рости кішки на коли
мечі та соціальні стипендії з перетином
місяця нею в бюджеті міністерство яку крім
програми штат особі вперше з вперше для
нас і так вже й нова функція для нас
навіть важливо його правильно відбито
ступні скільки ми оформлю в цій
паспорт та бюджетний цех нових програм
адже видно і закону їхні члени
повалюється повз нього 45 денних форм
лення підп родні програми еко шубу до
прийнятої у хвалений бюджет парламентом
рудне місяць це як плану ці тугім і
травня move продажів 45 днів на до
оформлення паспарту бюджетні програми
адже можна фінансово не своїх програм
в нашому університеті їм в підсумку можемо
розподіляти зі своїх програм кошт і на
університети знайдіть стипендії
підтвердити агус простий то
питання сантиментам за раз і або
правопорядку просто не бюджетного псування
затримується відписуватися та не біжить
затискаємо на скутері спекотніше не прийняті
лайнери заз гібіскусі чернецова і в
принципі я важливо ще й аптеці куди
ухвалений бюджет
де всі кристали приблизно youtube
зупинок і є великі цицьки
високоякісного виступання ритмічно
підняти томуза зустрічаємося ми стали підлогу
волю божу за людьми величезним можна навіть
ми газу те що бюджет міністерства середовища
супершоу рсн нини юмін сік банан і
зменшуватися але сади та до речі вони кулі
он і не в бюджеті мінсоцполітики за 1 е
900 дев'ятсот дев'яносто три тисячі
ви майже білизну не ціль 993 мільйони
гривень у нашому бюджеті та 2 мільярди на
соціальні стипендії
теж я видаю ви пропустили purchase лайк
я так розумію ну поварниці на польші
класу
подавитися вилазка в проекті бюджету
якийсь за раз е2 978 з соціальною склянкою
різьблених 2 мільярди в нашому бюджеті 978
у бюджеті міксів з політикою та 2
мільярди на академічно ми просимо у
зібрана
одну силу сім десятих мільярда на
академічно the game з пак і йому
стипендії і простяг моєму юшку плані
стипендіям та статеві на сходи столітті
зараз навчається на бюджет
так ні
ми на пробу ну йому норму про 52 сотки в
законі можна 70 тис але можна 70 можна
зменшити stp не погуляти і ту ж просто
можна зрубати взяті з менше ти
стипендії та дати стоїть цілодобово сильний за
лише на вигляд результативною ціною
давайте так із рогом
cipro академічно стратегії так вище
закон щось писати 130 там casa para чого
у рішенні ряду є червоні
ми у рішенні уряду е за війні критерії
аліасами
м'язів поряд tab tab a100 новий
кабміну дозволяючи йому кожному
університету у межах цех критерії
великі ми даємо а у вирішенні ряду
а сама випустять і 9010 добу на у
тебе рятувати не критерії я кіпр і
мовчана рада за отриманням суданського
самоуправління
процесів і триматися скажу що особа
зима не
стадо не наступи назвала дискусія
містер томас святі ми
принципі схожу на традиційні які
жінки тобі значно рази пулково
Аліна чому троянда сексуа таких груп
основний і що ви проти ще ми показали
надходить значення вчили совку на користь
це щоденник за нашими позиціями.
43 тис якщо нас ти особи може бути
штучно 25 ірисами на те що
показав ще ми до 20 руб. зі смаком
йшло на церкві біля ліжка назад цей
youtube сама ти показувати звуки
кріпись
коли нічого таки щаблі
місця прагнуть
Я сказав, що
нижче вам доведу
с.
просимо на чай політика легше сказати
ще стрип тенденції плата за 1000
почалися метою тривожності та землі
розумієш, що ось ще раз вимагає центер
промо понятих держави в тому що їм від
його вати мужики расисти
ще поважають наш абсолютно ну такі щітки
ступаєте сходами на кшталт каналі рахунку
скаржилася туди ні сюди
просто
я сприймаю сходить до
1410 ніж
я перефарбовую по чорних по чорних
у нас є ці розробки
я вам зі пропливала модель на суму нас
та дві моделі porsche модель дженна ми
можемо почути і себе в чині та парадигмі
така кого ноги за вишиті всі ці
підходи доступний дивного за посвячення
четвер а стійку я здається так куди
боїться університету шевченка ми можемо у
все чує і так і від е і в шахти кішки
вік що ми перекинемо один і сім
мільярда всі зали шитися так і вікні
я хочу зі всієї за долар звільняючи
і їх жартує з шоном потрібно будь ласка
алло я розумію що сьогоднішня система
надання 100 пандей нозі ефективну ми
ось його йому ниною гарніше а мило у того
йому всіх аки найкраще і хизуються геть і від
рибу і ту ж маленьку ризницю
упарювання їх не під вийшли на стипендії
то стипендія яким exit сарів
а інший там, що тривали ваші там
відриваємо менше кіль кисть
менше кирки сходи ось прямі 100
тенге чи там у сама система ієни
правильно ми по ви не систему мене ти
вони 2 з 4 ну хибну систему
позиція google
і c і душі чітки розробили шахти кішки
нікін які ми проповідуємо якушева
передам один і сім мільярдів на
академічно щаблем
cfc русакова ну
честь очисти законі
хвилину зовсім зникли сочі
давайте в частині ось мета плескати стрим
я просто уявіть самі видавці
поняття і підкоряєтеся
після ти вчився і хто на дзеркальність
чіп та й
бензильний туди затягла чоловік акції
протесту з балона
шантаж не за те, що він хоче нас
круті бої теж глибші
я навіть красивіша
кожного дня і заступ побачать вони
засипали
я йду розенталь ще ось з'їм це
надумано собою stabboard установка рахунок
масового що виявлюся їм недоступні для
міністра фінансів та
вчинарку офіційний м'яч після 1500
рублів
там точно людей до зв'язку обожнюєш
чоловік знаходить ні способу ти назвав
федор гнучкий робота запускає
допускаючим
за раз склади багато в чому сидиш і трицепси не
залишиться означаючого люди
сама одружилися випробування ти чого, не
судно
вони майже не зможете почати аналіз жити
залишивши mushi nissan
стипендія німа ніби й поглинати
виживання ціни я цілував їх будь ласка
царству тимби трушу
ми
тато заснути покладемося практикуються
карті
про викладені він сховав золото я поясню
почати їх що ми виходимо на соціальному
сходинкою тисячі ігор його не в нас
туди тюбики зажадають накриваючі широко
1700 на весь
так ми ми шлюбу вами я сказала ми з
запасом він же на мову а ну вали все
категорії театри малий і так і праві всіх
нас височіє той же у джен на виплату
всіх спеціально ступенем проти 8 місяці
потрібно 320 мільйонів гривень значить ми
пропадаємо за вишиті тобто 390
мільйонів гривень фонд соціальної
стипендії і один із себе шумить беремо 1
сен на економічніше тут ми можемо
та 24 соток 440 від 3 особи такою ознакою
до 49 особа я чекатиму вже важливі ось
тут шкіра на обличчя так моє значення едд
Світланова мета на Світлана сильно нас
які означає ми ми прогавили
я притрушую там ще й і димова
просочення sweet сотку академічних
стипендій такту і тому я хочу будемо
а ти один із семи цифр
гостям йому 45 academy
коріння 100 мільйонів c2 вигляд 100 студентів
кожна 40 мільйонів
що змінюється боїться птахів дуже якийсь
пов'язаного сального варіанту чия
але вона хоче виявлені сел 1c проект я
хочу щоб все відразу милої ціни та
проголосовані рішенню ряду колір початок
але стартовий документ від актором і коли
я кажу ось цю виходили на 52
сотки
розум соціальному і ступінь m&c маренні від
атак вівці в цик цифр активи за 1
владимир touch представляє цю мету 49
плюс 7 соціальної також виходить кеди
адже себе честь сотні
нові топ їжі себе чисто ціни акцій вона
тому що ми вчора гранично все
розробляємо
потрібно заявляти і менше за нижчий
своїм 4 свій хто планетоїд будь-яким
сваримося
ці звуки ворогом
я кгц і ми
я люблю що the correct розглядаються
ти найкраща
тому що гул і ми говоримо про 45
адже сотки в людей
який найкраще на курсі найкраще підсади
сім'ї найкраще і даємо у чоловіка без
вищому початковому захопленню та поставить
йдуть від кави критерії для покуду
такого рейтингу ціни їв середи на четвер
ай-q початку це сесії я
функція update 8 5 3 так тоді пропана
це я щоб я куїмова такого зростання хунг
unimat з
з 40 виходить помітно 75 і twitter ти
визнаний законним
будемо йому розвиватися фантастика
Місто
запри завдань від дискусію і знову законом
а цьому стрибку крім його на неподалік
ось цей служить наш
я пізнала
нашим меншим. canonical а це тільки
якому інтубацію ролик буде легко you ми
зазвичай
несмак з мінфін він просто спів і я
прошу його більше немає
ямб ми не ви кликаєте я я по війна за
роз'їхатися на ступню.
я також вигукнули, але ви більше не володимир
витальович porsche та заступник міністра
продовж і далі vst дискусію і ви
давно точу даю вам слово
рік ласка